as the war in ukraine enters its 11th
week meps will discuss its repercussions
and how it's impacting the eu
they'll also debate what more the eu can
do to support the kiev government
stepping up sanctions on russia and
belarus and support for refugees
especially women
parliaments will vote on the conclusions
of its special committee on artificial
intelligence the report calls for the eu
to set global standards and harness ai's
potential in areas like health and
climate change while protecting people
from possible risks
the european parliament is currently
elected using different voting systems
across eu member states parliament will
put forward new proposals for the 2024
european elections including a list of
meps representing the eu as a whole
there are a myriad of different phone
charges on the market they generate more
than 11 000 tons of e-waste every year
parliaments will set its position on
proposals to make the usb-c charger the
industry standard in the eu
so-called forever chemicals from things
like waterproof material become
increasingly concentrated in recycled
products posing a risk to human health
meps will vote on new rules to reduce
the amount of persistent organic
pollutants in the recycling chain for a
clean safe circular economy